another staffer is set to depart vice
president kamala harris's office this
time it's deputy chief of staff michael
fuchs who is now the 12th person to
leave her staff since june joe koncha
joins us now joe at this rate will there
be anyone left to turn out the lights
oh man todd carly we have not seen a
mass exodus like this since uh people
jumped myspace and friendster for
facebook right i mean it's just like all
right we're out of here because i think
these folks know a losing hand when they
see one and that's why we're seeing
people leave kamala harris at this
unprecedented rate uh that we've never
seen for any vice president anyway and
to voters just like her staffers that
she seems to have the same problem right
it's their problems i should say
likeability problem authenticity problem
and she just doesn't seem very
interested in doing her job whether
that's fixing the border or whether it's
just basic prep for appearances in terms
of her public comments
she seems to be in this for the
celebrity aspect and perhaps that's why
she's polling in the 30s right now as
far as approval and why she just can't
seem to hold on to her own staff because
reports say and these are from
left-leaning publications she's not the
easiest person to work with unlike carly
who's exceptionally easy to work out
guys i appreciate it and you know joe i
was going to ask you about hillary
clinton because she's out there doing
the sunday shows and doling out advice
um saying that you know the body
administration needs to double down on
pressure on russia democrats have a
messaging disconnect and you have to
wonder with kamala harris failing what
hillary clinton is thinking about her
political future
right see a majority of voters including
many democrats don't want joe biden to
run so plan b is supposed to be kamala
harris and she's pulling way down here
and has all those problems like we spoke
of so then who backfills is it pete
buddha judge who has a supply chain
crisis on his resume and looks like he
should be running for student council
president instead of actual president
probably not andrew cuomo yeah i don't
think so and you go down the list amy
klopichar elizabeth warren bernie
sanders who's you know now into his 80s
uh the bench isn't very deep so when
hillary clinton says things like this
presents herself as the moderate
you got to believe that somewhere in the
back of her mind she's thinking that
well if things start to fall apart for
this administration i got more votes
than donald trump in 2016.
why not me considering i'm a big brand
name and i deserve it anyway at least
that's what hillary thinks in her own
mind i think you're right just one final
tie up here to the kamala karli thing
carly's been to europe uh washington
post columnist praising joe biden's
failing economy amid soaring inflation
here is the quote from the article that
is mind-blowing it says if it weren't
for inflation this president's economic
performance would be unmatched
aside from that mrs lincoln how did you
enjoy the play does she not realize that
inflation negates literally all of that
yeah it's like saying if it wasn't for a
bad economy jimmy carter and george bush
41 would have been re-elected right this
is the thing that takes down presidents
because it's a tax on everyone charlie
gasparino says it best he says inflation
is theft and you think about the low and
middle class and all the things all the
additional money they're spending on
food and for gas and for home heating
and
all this stuff that costs people so much
money that people feel so yeah to make
this argument that if you take away the
one very big thing that impacts
everybody uh then he's doing great as
you said how'd you like to play mrs
lincoln great point you stole my line
todd thanks exactly i also saw you on
twitter if not for the iceberg the
titanic would have been successful
yeah the options are endless joe thank
you so much for joining us see you
tomorrow